well the thing is it's not the the thing
on the left about uplifting women and
you know not attacking or harassing
women that only stands for women that
share the same leftist ideology it
doesn't actually
mean that there's support for
conservative women emma joe i think that
you've probably seen this as well well
of course i mean i remember
like when we were doing the hunter stuff
you know we were talking about it and
and i was thinking about you know
obviously what the backlash would be and
i was thinking about it and i you know
check all these boxes for the people
that kind of you know come after you
with the pitchforks and and i was
thinking okay i'll be home free because
i'm exactly who they would want to
uplift you know and i'm breaking a story
and it's a big story and i'm a young
woman and uh you know i'm an immigrant
and which story was it specifically just
for people who don't know
i broke the hunter biden laptop story um
that was my scoop and i went through the
laptop and i
wrote all the articles uh leading up to
the election that got the new york post
uh kicked off twitter and facebook so i
brought the internet basically i i can
just imagine that all of the democrats
were cheering like here's a prominent
female journalist proving that you know
shattering the glass ceiling i wasn't
going that far i wasn't going that far
but i was thinking that they wouldn't
attack me personally you know i
obviously figured they would go after
the story but i figured that
i
kind of fall into a lot of their
protected classes that you often see and
i wasn't expecting that the backlash
would be so personal because of that oh
dude these are these people man they're
nasty people but listen but you know
what you're saying about cassandra
i don't know about her opinions or nor
do i care because it shouldn't really
matter it should be about the work that
she does and what she produces for you i
would think and that was something that
came out from the whole thing with you
know after we broke the internet and
after you know the new york times came
after me and washington post and joy
read and npr and whatever
you know all the polite people
and uh and the post didn't even wince
you know that not only were they
expecting it and not only did they not
care but they were just kind of looking
at the story on its merits and uh
whatever the people were looking at on
my instagram of pictures from when i
worked at fox you know that was one
thing that they were pulling up that i'm
a
you know trump apparatchik because i
used to work at fox and i had all these
pictures from when i just got out of
school i was like 23 and i was meeting
all these trump people who were coming
to fox and taking pictures and posting
them and that was supposed to be proof
that i was like a political hack
and you know the employer didn't care
because at the end of the day it's like
what work are you doing and if we're
going to appease like a twitter mob that
you know they come and go like the wind
and it's you can't you can't run a
business that way and uh and that's why
canceling trying to cancel me personally
didn't work and that's why it won't work
considering and it won't work with any
business that doesn't bend to it because
if you just don't care it just passes
like a storm right right i think
conservatives also need to stop
thinking that these people have
legitimate complaints
so
for whatever reason
i think people on the right
whatever you want to call it because
there's certainly liberals who are
anti-woke anti-establishment as well
although many of them are becoming
conservative
they seem to think that these people
maybe are just misguided
and that if we just have a conversation
calmly and rationally they'll change
their minds that's just absolutely not
true it's just just not the case it is
so divergent right now this the the
political factions in this country
there's a bunch of different ones some
are aligned with others but the gap
between
those people who are screaming at you
and calling you a russian agent or
whatever and saying normal people
there's no bridge
there's no words you can say there's no
convincing them and and many of them
probably know they're they're nasty evil
disgusting vile people they they they're
trolls who go look at chrissy tygan for
instance right tegan or whatever her
name is she had that tweet where this
guy was begging her please take down
that fake post i never said those words
and she's like too bad you're a racist
and i'm gonna watch you burn they know
they're evil they know it well they
think they're entitled because they
think that they're right and they think
that they're right because they never
examine their views they don't examine
the undercurrents
uh
that are that are holding their
perspectives in place and they would
find that they're not there i mean these
liberal ideologies are like shifting
sands you know you stand in one place
and then suddenly you're somewhere else
because nothing there's no stability
underneath these uh there's no
foundations to it so if we're not
consistently and constantly examining
our belief systems to try and understand
what we believe and why you know i say
this all the time then we then we have
nothing and we have nothing at all i
don't think it's a belief system i
wouldn't i no i don't think it's that
sincere
i think it's a it's like a character
it's a personality it's somebody who's
ready to take a bludgeon and hit
whoever's in front of them um i mean
come on this isn't like about morality
it's about it's about having like
chrissy teigen it's about having the
right to push somebody around and get
praise for it um but like you said it's
like shifting sounds there's no
continuity there's no like
i think they just think there's no
you don't think so
i think they think that they have a
moral superiority about it i think that
that's a shroud yeah that's something
that's used to like get props for what
they're doing but i think underneath
that it's just more about
control and and
i don't want to use the word
yeah it's about bullying i think
arsonist yeah yeah they they they take
pleasure and destruction
so those uh those those direct messages
that got released showing chrissy
teigen's messages the story i guess
basically is this guy was accused of
being racist because someone
photoshopped him saying i guess the n
word
and he chrissy takes okay when you're
hunter biden though right right right
well so chrissy teigen posts an image i
guess on instagram or something like
that he messages messages her saying
please i never said those things to fake
photo like this is this is destroying me
and he was having suicidal ideation and
she's just laughing she's like hahaha i
don't care screw you you're racist you
deserve it but he didn't actually say
those things she doesn't care she comes
out later and admits yeah i was a troll
i was screwing with people it is what it
is these are just evil people who enjoy
watching others suffer i don't think
it's even evil i think it's like an
insecure husk
you know like if you think about like
who does that
it's people who who need a source of
like feeling good about themselves that
doesn't come from anything other than
kind of like
imposing whatever they're doing and then
getting likes for it i mean watching
someone suffer and laughing about it
that's like that that feels evil to me
well a lot of this is the definition of
mirth yeah mirth is taking joy in
someone else's pain a lot of this is
also surrounding narcissism and ego and
what we were talking about earlier these
social media algorithms that incentivize
it and
and reward it if you look at what gets
promoted what gets talked about what the
algorithm pushes on the general public
it's usually drama it's usually fighting
it's usually putting someone down and
it's promoting the larger divide and
conquer agenda that makes people want to
attack each other and not really truly
look at the true cause of their problems
in their lives so i i think you know
there is an element of evil you know
cats torture animals for some for for
some reason there is an element of just
that there is an element of business
incentive knowing that you're going to
get more followers more retweets more
likes if you do start that drama and i
think there's also even a bigger agenda
possibly even above that uh pushing
people to hate each other and fight each
other that also again psychologically
people are doing without even knowing
that they're doing it themselves there's
this viral thread from some like
crackpot guy who's like fascism is back
here's proof and it was the story about
ron desantis been in critical race
theory in florida and then he just like
creates this
weird version of reality where what
ronda sanchez is doing is comparable to
what the nazis did i guess which makes
no sense and then he just like he's like
the nazis were banning you know
knowledge and books and this is it it's
happening and it's like bro you guys
have been banning books for years like
amazon literally bans was at burning
books and and these people genuinely are
freaking out waving their arms and
they're screaming that fascists are
taking over it is kind of funny when you
think about the right when they were
like ah the cultural marxists and the
communists are taking over and it's like
you know the thing is there's an
objective reality and if you read cbs if
you watch cbs and fox news you'll get a
hard dose of reality and say huh
i kind of understand what's what's
happening
the thing is conservatives according to
at least one study i cite a million in
one time i've cited a million and one
times
conservatives do read about a third of
their news from mainstream liberal
sources moderates read about a third of
their news from conservative sources
liberals 95 to 100 of their news comes
from liberal news sources that's exactly
what happens when i mean when i talk to
liberals
that i know the ones that are still
talking to me which are not that many
i'm mostly just in my family and they
don't really have a choice but anyway
yeah they don't see the same news that i
see at all there's just no there's
nothing to connect it yeah there's
there's it's hard to watch there was a
guy who got uh he's like a call of duty
gamer i guess and someone he tweeted
about a video about something political
and he was like this is crazy what's
happening someone said hey you should
watch like you should read glenn
greenwald matt tybee and watch tim cast
and then he said something like absurd
about me that was based on grifters who
will like pull clips from the show take
them out of context and then repackage
them and
there was a story about democrats and
segregation or something i can't
remember exactly which segment they were
talking about
but he said it's not true it's clearly a
line i won't even watch the video and
then i mentioned something about
democrats even at the federal level
signing on to about to repeal
uh uh the the anti-discrimination the ra
the anti-racial discrimination policies
from their constitution constitution in
california
all of these democrats like even at the
national level were saying to california
like yes we agree with you removing your
anti-discrimination provision in your
own constitution so that they could
implement racial policies in
universities which is that we've seen
segregated dorms we've seen uh
race-based selection for for schools so
that i always tell i always tell people
what what the democrats want to do with
with universities is
there's a kid whose skin is too much of
one color and you know so they tell you
you can't go to the school you look too
much like those other people that's
literally what their plan is this guy
responds with well why haven't i seen
that story because you're not looking
for it guy well if all you're reading is
fake news
like at this point it is so painfully
obvious that the mainstream media is
just like more than half lies i'm not
gonna say it's all lies there's a lot of
really basic stuff i mean we're reading
a lot of this news right now clearly the
video of the guy shoplifting that story
from market watch is a real story you
can watch the video but when it comes to
politics it's just
word vomit they just make up trash well
they are making up trash and i think
that you know you mentioned desantis
banning critical race theory in schools
and that gets picked up by you know your
attacker joy reed and other people by
say you know and they're saying that uh
they're banning the actual teaching that
slavery existed and you know and it's
like none of that is true and if you
actually look at the bills that are that
are coming up in these legislatures uh
they're saying things like you cannot
teach that one race or ethnicity is
better than another right right right
you know it's like doubling down on
actual
uh anti-discrimination policy and the
thing too is critical you know the
another thing that's coming out now is
this idea that critical race theory is
not being taught and the left is like no
critical race theory isn't being taught
that's not what's going on and no
critical race theory is not being taught
it's being embedded in pedagogy it's
being completely you know linked in with
every aspect of curriculum so that you
can't take it out it's not that it's
being taught it's being indoctrinated
there's a difference but the thing
that's such a troll now is like
nicole hannah jones or is that her name
1619 yeah she's on twitter like this is
why
you know because it's starting to be
banned and that's now proof
that it's all true so so but but uh you
are completely right it's indoctrination
and
they're
so if they want to teach about critical
race theory great why are we teaching
fifth graders about an academic college
level theory
what they're actually doing is teaching
the ideology of it but more importantly
like you were saying when they come out
they're like no one's teaching this
technically they're telling the truth
they are telling the truth there was
this really great meme image i saw i
didn't say it to me it went viral it was
an image from a workbook from a grade
school
you ever you you know the old trope of
the school the school math question a
train leaves pittsburgh traveling at 70
miles an hour a train leaves cincinnati
traveling at 40 miles an hour if they're
just if they're this far apart how long
until they crash or whatever
there was this problem that was getting
shared around and it said it showed a
picture of a white guy and a black guy
and it said john is a white man who has
been stopped by the police three times
in the past year
harold is a black man who's been stopped
394 times if the difference is like
what's the percentage of times the black
man has been harassed by police
something like that like that's
indoctrination it sure is totally
unrelated things that are using the the
the cult ideology in in just
like you were mentioning right in
math problems that are unrelated that's
how they get they get it right it's in
math problems it's in art classes it's
in history it's in literature it's in
literally every aspect of it and when
they're done with you know embedding
critical race theory and everything uh
they're also and they're also pushing in
um climate alarmism as well not to take
anything away from climate change being
a thing but teaching kids
what opinions to have before you give
them facts
about what's going on is
that's indoctrination you know what you
know
when it comes to the climate change
stuff i think the global elites are
betting on winning because they're
buying beachfront property
so they're basically telling everybody
like hey if all of you give up all of
your luxuries we'll save the world by
the beachfront in miami because
their bet is if we make all the poor
people own nothing we get our private
jets we get our yachts we get our
beachfront property that's the plan baby
there was a
hysterical thing that happened yesterday
where in new zealand there's a
what is it schools
schools climate strike school strike for
climate it's like the greta thunder
thing and there's branches everywhere so
the auckland branch of the school
strikes for climate decided that they
were going to completely disband they
were formed in 2019 but there's too much
systemic racism in their group of eight
to 18 year olds
so they've decided to completely disband
stop dealing with the climate thing at
all and only uplift the
black indigenous people of color who are
working to do it so all the white people
are like you know what we can't possibly
do this work because we're not you so
y'all do this work and we'll we'll pump
you on social media okay and that's how
we know we're anti-racist that's amazing
it's like we burned down your
neighborhood in riots and we think you
should rebuild it because it's yours
it's yours you guys deal with it you
guys know better than us so we're gonna
go sit over here
we you know worthless white people we
got thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you